you
Jung arena is officially kicked off its
king of the hill get your king in the
center and you win I'm going to do this
and remove your Center pond I want to
run my King right up caveman style let's
go right away mmm
let's eliminate that in any piece who
tries to this has already win the
supreme of that came over back to turn
watch out for the crazy King attack
central centralize that king who - - I'm
on the front page remove center pawns
challenge center pounds with flank pawns
wow really
all right I'll do the same
let's go here I got it again kingi key
five key five this my test Wow
well that's a pretty uh that's a pretty
quick that's a fast track towards
victory huh
King e7 King e6 king e5 Wow
four and a bunch of two's get rid of oh
okay this you're not gonna have that
easier time
No
nothing going to happen let's force you
back and I'm not gonna take that pie I
feel like he's poison let's do this I'm
gonna get my king up I'm not castling
inch the king up you take me
prove my night position
let's go here I'm thinking king d6
although that's a little crazy town
isn't it
pawn takes pawn King takes game over
king e5 again strikes rook here let's go
here take him I want this pawn out of
here so I have king e5 ideas
alright let's support that Bishop he's
going nowhere
uh kick this night away I'll only have
24 seconds I only have 24 seconds let's
kick the night away they're gonna kick
my night away no you leave
oh really take that here I get to remove
that pond King here's a threat game over
King defied back to tournament 8/8 - I'm
the only one in streak land of course
I'm not too many people still playing
their second game actually 30 players
are in this one pop shepherd I played
you in the cyma alright let's do this
undermine their pond have them give up
their strong point I want you to give up
your pond here that's what I'm looking
for and I'm gonna play my king up - e -
I'm not castling so quick okay this is a
very welcome sight Bishop check I'll
gladly bump up here let's let's actually
do it right now if they're not careful
they're in big trouble let's remove that
Knight twice and then jump up to e4 I'm
playing this much more aggressively than
in the past
okay stay here and take that
this is a main to threat King here to
here cannot be stopped
rook here could be played but I just
take and then here next Queen here they
might have to play Queen d5 but I'm just
getting a queen
King d3 to e4 sneak-attack clean here is
the only way to stop it
pawn takes pawn takes let's pick that up
Queen here is needed cream of that
otherwise its king here mate okay
just get to the center clean here take
the pawn and then insist on getting to
this square here next that's game over
back to turn 12 for four I get I've been
practising I think I have I have I been
practicing king of the hill I haven't
it's just a different way to look at it
remove the center pawn don't be so quick
to castle this is welcome this is
definitely welcome I'm not castling my
king up right now
see five I'll be faster towards the
center it's difficult to work around
this pun
okay King here soon whoa
Wow let's give a check get out of there
get out of there man you're getting a
piece but I will be kicking the King
away soon
um let's just do that I'm losing a piece
but I want to drive them away from the
center ask this this is close to mate
let's give a check I just made them
that's made back to tournament sixteen
eight eight eight eight
what an interesting start to this
tournament too pretty quick kills with
the king e5 move twenty three minutes
remain hmm right
all right here we go
hmm let's start with this d5 you have 15
seconds to make your first move
hmm let's go here I'm gladly allow that
kind of capture
let's get that Bishop out of here also
this is an idea that's an interesting
idea
Queen takes King here not quite let's
see if I could kick the Queen away have
ideas of King here still let's go hear
that Queen out of there
here there's Bishop takes that's maybe
too
crazy let's give a check pawn push is
available clean takes um let's get the
rook here my king is close I want a
queen trade let's do this I should have
done that sooner okay let's get closer
one of these two let's do this
I want this square opened up I'm losing
my rook but could I have something in
less than 20 seconds this isn't a good
move but
one step away they're using up a lot of
time okay I feel like I shouldn't as
long as I don't fall for a mate in one
or something I'll be fine less than five
three two one
and anything they're gonna definitely be
down on time back to tournament my King
was one step away but no square was
cleared out for him I was still trying
to make that happen hmm
in those cases with the King coming up
really close in the early stage having
the Queens exchanged okay this I got a
knock this guy off here he's the one
that's in second he keep the Queens on
the board if the King runs wild towards
the center get rid of this pun okay he's
I'm trying to have him act as a thorn
okay my king is gonna inch up now he's
creeping closer I want to get rid of the
knight so I could play King to e4 I have
a Bishop b5 check they're stopping that
but I wanna get rid of their knight
Knight there huh okay
still gonna go here could undermine this
pawn queen D Ford's strong move Queen D
for Queen D Fuu hmm let's stop this pawn
from pushing take the night if question
with h6
or even on time
Nate has to take
and
I want to just remove this night
Queen takes and I take the night okay
Queen takes Knight as a threat I got
this difficult to stop my king from
getting here have to attack my bishop
yeah
I can do this though give a check
hack the Queen kick her off of defense
of this square Queen before a3 Bishop
check might be good
Bishop check now I don't know Bishop
check now the bish was pinned okay I get
the Queen ready to move remove this pawn
king here next can't be stopped
the bishop spin back to tournament they
resigned 24 1612 less than 20 minutes
remain
um okay the jeonga Rena let's keep it up
here I have still in streak mode that
was an important victory I could have
really changed things up there to lose
your streak and have your opponent still
be in a streak there let's go with that
for challenge any Center pond with two
pieces get rid of that night King f2
let's just get rid of him
King f2 to here and I think I am close
to winning exchange Queens I'm gonna
take that e5 pawn
we're not moving
let's go here caveman style you have to
stop me from getting 2d for Queen trade
Queen trade and mate c5 I take and then
Queen here okay now I'm gonna look to
deflect the rook away from defense of d4
almost there I'm getting a rook or
winning the game with King to d4 okay I
get the rook instead next phase is to do
what develop and move fast the time is
even just take once and then push this
pawn away they have to stop King here
now he's then the restricted piece let's
kick him away with the pawn okay keep
attacking that piece that's defending
this square get rid of him and then King
to e4 I'm pushing through with that that
piece is dropping only pawn pushes
available I just take okay now it's back
to tournament I would have just taken
and then mate next 28 2016 16 17 minutes
remain okay less than 17 okay alright
let's see if they take okay let's grab
some space space is good
space is very good
in this variant let's get rid of their
night like how well let's push another
pun up and this is a beastly center I
already feel like I could sack my queen
let's do this
kick the knight out of here
okay I'm just gonna challenge him gladly
allow this you get this pawn who really
interesting they have control with those
two pawns they have control over these
two squares don't want a castle they
could scoop up this pawn my night
working King to e2
it's the one that scares me queen
development stop b4
what next 22
castled look 4g5 hmm I get the h5 they
take okay
I can't no let's go here opposite get
off of that file now take I've night
here it could end in me actually some
cases they're not careful
let's take here I have enough on it
control this
maybe even queen here looking for made
on these squares I could take that with
check he gets to go here another down no
they resigned back determine 30 whoa 32
30 Povich
Carol Kahn put pressure on the strong
point keep going
remove ponds that are in the center okay
all right let's get rid of your knight
inch my king closer it's already
dangerous it's already very dangerous
the king is wild but it puts such a
restriction on the minor pieces they're
frozen
okay let's remove this bishop I want to
remove any piece
stay here I'm on the Queen okay
sneaky move threatening mate there's
night Fork I have this threatening the
knight and threatening mate with King e4
oh they could take the Queen words check
but I'm still on their queen so they
could take my queen with check no take
my queen with check King here is game
over
so I'm attacking the Queen the night uh
I'll take the night still on their queen
and my king let's bump up my king is
very close let's get my rook over here
I'm a time edge okay I have a fast track
towards this square they're not they're
not close with their King either
let's get that Queen out of here and do
this I want to get my King in here can
it be stopped let's do this first um 15
seconds Oh deadly fork another fork
another fork right here is available oh
boy eight seconds oh no got a pre move
huh
oh wow what a delayed reaction I didn't
have a time to look at the time another
one of those cases they're awful when
you don't have time to look at the time
and all you see in the corner your eye
is just the red you know someone's in
red and you're not quite sure who it is
okay let's go out of pun let's do
something good would you okay we've kind
of been here before this is this the
same player
okay I'm gonna chip away I should have
taken with my deep on first run towards
the center or right now remove the dark
square Bishop here here and then okay
let's do like this pressure on this pond
get rid of their Bishop Knight takes
pawn let's give a check their King is a
little bit too close okay
pawn push dangerous it's very dangerous
this is helpful okay should have this
should should is the key word okay
tonight is gonna be scary
um I guess here stop the night from
getting into f4 let's do this with check
night has to block I take with the rook
okay I have everything under control
let's go here
remove this pawn alright the pawn is
removed I just want to move my pawn out
of the way but I have to be careful why
am I not getting to the center like
yesterday take here back up push my pawn
and then I have this square covered
that's me Oh
back determined they were kicking and
kicking it into a higher gear there's
starting to speed up there forty twenty
four twenty to ten minutes remain so far
so good
thirty-five players are entered now
ok-hee 4p 4d 4f 4 even if he could take
this pawn could be poison I'm not gonna
take the night
I want to go for more okay
Queen Wow let's give this check and now
avoid the threat on the Queen now I'm
gonna take the knight no let's take here
first queenside castle no I don't want
to castle at all I take my knight that
the coast is clear a bit more tough to
stop my king from oh that's got to be a
mouse lip okay how you stopping King
here you're not back to tournament kingi
for forty four twenty eight twenty to
twenty twenty okay this guy I gotta get
paired up with them this is a
significant lead forty four to twenty
eight see if I could keep it up see if I
could get paired up there we go Popovic
again okay let's still go with this two
pawns challenge any center pawn playing
his white that's the that's what I'm
shooting for
let's keep them on this diagonal and get
that night out of here King up pave the
way to get my King on this square
tough to stop the dart of the
LightSquared bishop is a long way off
gotta play f5
so no time for c5 and having this guy
controlled
um let's take and run away um let's go
here pawn takes it's dangerous okay I
gotta go faster my king is still closed
okay I feel comfortable now King up
okay I've King D for get rid of the dark
square Bishop this this should be good
now I got this one pretty sure my king
is way too advanced in this queenless
middle game feels weird to use like
regular chess terms and a king in the
hill game but you know okay I'm just
gonna remove this guy and then take the
knight no candy for that's mate that's
game over forty eight twenty eight
twenty two twenty two of this guy is
still in a streak mode seven minutes
remaining feels like more of a race oh
no he is 32 now we might get paired up
that that game just finished yes we are
paired up so this is the guy in second I
don't think it should be any great worry
even if he wins but for the tournament
standing but I want to still finish out
good okay let's go with this pin the
night if he's attacking my queen take
that night kingi to hang on let's defend
I'm taking that and get two pawns for
the minor piece
and
yeah let's do that
tack the knight King here to here maybe
one of these two squares available in
fact you can't stop King D for mate next
back to tournament yeah you needed to
keep Bishop c5 open fifty two thirty two
twenty five twenty four six minutes
remaining thirty seven players not too
many more entered all right six minutes
Kovac again all right
let's challenge that poem I'm just going
to do this kind of a gambit my night out
get my bishop out we'll get my king up
okay they're not taking that pun go
ahead take him go ahead and take him now
we're gonna get rid of the light square
bishop
not so fast not so fast attack that
Queen next she's close to trapped
she is definitely close to trapped
still very close to trapped Queen here
though I miss that move can I take my
rook I might be able to give him up
I just might be able to
taking him out and I'm inching my king
up watch out for me here pawn push as
well King here is the threat I can move
my Bishop and attack their Queen less
than 20 seconds
stay right here Queen trade King here
next this should be winning even though
I'm down a rook undermine this pawn here
okay I'm hittin the night if he moves as
soon as he moves I get here um keep this
closed I think let's back up King here
take the night and then go here I don't
know about that bro check no good don't
have any time though Wow oh they're so
down on time that they had to start
doing crazy stuff okay now I'm getting
here next they're down on time back to
term and I've started to pose some
problems so that ate up some clock time
I'm pretty sure 56 34 30 one more game
two maybe alright 56 34 30 25 quick stir
okay I like to Scandinavian wow this is
too much I think we're gonna see hmm
okay let's go here wow you could already
do that can't you
um
okay what is going on here let's get
this pawn up at least I have him to
control dark squares get out of there
please now I could take here and I'm
going to start moving my king up a
little bit now that their King has been
flushed back just a hair
it's taking why did I do that
ah you goof why did I take that King
here is a killer I have that move but if
they take I lose
I can't even stop their king from
getting there
yeah I don't have anything yeah too easy
I made that too easy King e for game
over
ah man 5640 32:26 why would I take their
night and invite their king closer to
the center ah that was silly less than 2
okay let's end on a good one here fancy
night man
man they played King E tooth and this in
that last game too so early I know I
know how it is I did the same thing I've
been doing the same thing alright I like
this king of 7 move castle by hand
there we go Queen v6 put pressure on
their center chip away at these Center
pawns
it's taken
going here
take that night just yet now I will and
then what I want to play pawn up you
know let's try this light squares
they're vulnerable on their light
squares King up King here make threat
pond takes pawn might be tempting pawn
push here secure my king they missed
that 41 seconds remain back to terminate
5844 that's probably gonna be a no more
games in 33 seconds yeah that should be
the last one let's check out a game
that's currently going on nope that one
just finished up Qwikster he's gonna end
up getting third this is the guy that
nicked me
king de - why did I take the night in
that game 15 seconds remain
58 44 32 it should stay just like that
will be the top three here 39 total
players in this one for the Jung arena
and that is officially it all right good
games huh final standings here just
scrolling up a hair make sure I get it
on screen there we go final standings
these are all the players and there we
go alright to the 39 of you who took
part in the king of the hill tournament
Jung arena GG's all right
you